dort alle einig es war knapp herzlich
willkommen beim ein video ich muss nicht
gerade bei allen bei ich muss jetzt
sofort los auf jeden fall ein steht das
jetzt alles mega spontan ich glaube
rasiert richtig witzig ich würde sagen
mehr erfahrt ihr gleich ich weiß erst
mal los aber verspreche euch auf jeden
fall dranbleiben ich hab nämlich gerade
was cooles auf instagram entdeckt von
einer fanpage und das essen jetzt mal
die tat um als leistung
[Musik]
auf jeden fall mega den krassen lockt am
start als sonntag
da muss man sich nicht zwischen ganzen
[Musik]
ja ich bin 500
vielleicht also leute was auch folgendes
ich habe gerade von der fanpage alex
acker badboy dieses foto gefunden und
zwar ist er gerade dieses spiel gefreut
aber total in macht irgendwie jeder so
und hier steht eine flow ist alex unter
küsst halt irgendwie den boden jetzt
fast auf ich hole jetzt nämlich erst ab
den kennen wahrscheinlich die anderen
von euch und anderer kollege ist auch
dabei und ich haben halt so gesagt ja er
kommt das spielzeug so ein bisschen aus
spaß in den channel auch ein bisschen
einfach essen gehen und zu die wissen
halt nur nicht
ich will mit dem nichts neues lager
spielen sondern für alle also immer wenn
das wort kommt muss man halt den boden
küssen wenn drei sekunden so geht das
irgendwie ins mega spontan entstanden
gerade aber ich habe bock gefeiert los
und viel spaß mit dem video das nur rum
das geht ewig spielen übrigens nicht
böse aber sondern wurde es alles immer
wenn ich sage zum beispiel zu dir
der bonus alex musst du machen musst du
nicht wegrennen sondern hingehen worden
und sitzen weil der boden alexis zu
weiße alex so geil
also ich hab mir so gedacht zum beispiel
ich fange jetzt also nur als beispiel
wenn ich jetzt hier sagen würde dass
alex müsse zum beispiel heraus
irgendwohin schicken
und dafür hat man immer drei sekunden
zeit und wenn man fällt nicht schafft
dann verliert man warum meister 1 3
genau wenn man fern 83 sekunden schaffte
spielen das so lange bis einer verpackt
und der kriegt eine bestrafung
bestrafung sind okay
leider muss immer den boden weil der
boden ist auf alex sohn alex
erst mal einfach an uns läuft alles was
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
ich gebe es einfach die kamera weiter
zum beispiel ist ein herz und da darf
dann wieder ein von uns zweien
auszumachen der dax hat an die kamera
und auf auswählen
die kamera ist ein von den beiden
aussuchen gleich wer mit foto geholt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also leute ist auf jeden fall gar nicht
mal so schön einfach irgendwie geht
irgendwie gedacht das ist schwerer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also ich bin ehrlich zu ich habe mich
ganz ehrlich das dann so viele leute
drum lasst uns getraut vor allem hätte
mich doch angeguckt
was möchten sie gerne möchten so leute
das war's mit dem video auf jeden fall
nach oben da lassen
bei hertha hat gestern sich für aufgaben
ganz oben in der beschreibung von links
solltet euch mal an und und auch bei
baris vorbeischaut auch angefangen
youtube ist auch der kanal in der video
beschreibung abonniert das mal und wir
sehen uns mit noch wieder ein paar
klausuren schreiben v 3 2